today I'm a special roundtable episode
of game life we talked to game designer
Mike Micah and supergiant games Greg
cassava about what video game we would
most like to hack into ooh is this the
part where I get to say hack attack
asked you really nicely not to say hack
attack attack attack
today we're very pleased to be joined by
two game designers yes from other ocean
there is Mike Micah thank you happy to
be here at hello and from supergiant
games mr. Greg cassava hey hello Mike
now recently you mean you made some some
waves you make some I lose because you
hacked the game donkey kong so that your
daughter could live out her dream of
playing as the girl Pauline and Donkey
Kong and rescuing Mario was this
something new for you to go into a
previously existing game and change it
around I hadn't done it for a long time
in fact the way I learned how to program
was from hacking okay I would actually
change other games and figure out how
they worked and then I would learn from
that well here's a question what classic
game would you most like to hack and
what would you do to it I have a
daughter as well she's seven and i found
the story very very inspiring and it was
just trying to think of like actually
like a similar interesting case and and
the best i got is i wondered what it
would be like if you could take the
original Metroid and take like the
ending which which reveals that that
samus is a woman right it put that
sequence at the beginning rather than at
the end so it's not like the gotcha you
know ending because I feel that it's a
very important game you know one of the
first like prominent games like a female
protagonist but but they had a sort of
Trojan horse it in for that to be a
thing like they'd have just put it front
and center at least that's how I think
about it sometimes I should probably go
a little bit more classic than this but
my first choice is actually something
that is imminently hackable and moddable
obviously any game that was made with
the source code there was Gary's mod
that let you do just about anything with
some of those valve games but people do
that a lot with team fortress and they
change levels in Team Fortress I would
like to see team fortress change so you
have a bit more character elasticity
that you can maybe bring in characters
from other games I'd maybe like to see a
team of Gordon Freeman's take on some
scouts and heavies bring in some of the
gang from left for dead I think just you
know the the extended family of the
games under the valve umbrella has
enough potential for fun a kind of super
smash brothers style crossover that I'd
kind of like to make that happen or I'd
like to contract one of you to help me
right right well you know there's guys
out there that they do they hack super
smash brothers and they insert more
characters and they build 3d models of
new characters that they want in that
game and they will put them in there
that's something that the fighting game
community is actually done for along
with a movie in yeah yeah yeah yeah
which is just like everybody versus
everybody the fighting game where you
can have Homer Simpson versus you know
your dog yeah when you can just change
it as much as you want it's the least
balanced game on earth right um just cuz
Homer Simpson has the donut attack Oh
indeed yes he just destroys everything
but I but it's you know slices of
American cheese gone up energy before
you can use that one but that that
impetus that you have to like you wanna
you you like this game and you just want
to throw more stuff into it is one I
think you share Russell Krauss on
average i mean know what's better than
kind of seeing characters from one game
that you have pop up in another game and
that's like it's always the first thing
I think of when I think of a game hack
but I'm curious as Mike as someone who
has hacked stuff before yep what's your
what's your dream what's my dream you
know I'm Cinderella yes you're talking
like what is my dream game to hack and I
started hacking there's a game it was
called impossible mission on the company
before which was a pain in the ass was
all the hardest games ever that was the
very first hack I had ever done because
I wanted to beat that game so badly I
had to yank all the sprites out so I
would have no collision oh yes and so I
with a transfer like right now it's the
most immediate and most self-satisfying
hack that I could do would be the
bioshock infinite ending for that whole
airship attack and the songbird
attacking everything gone it killed me
killed a bear I was the worst part ever
and I'm done playing on easy I'm awful
at this game but I would hack that out
completely and just go straight to that
awesome ending that'd be my current heck
I would take a street fighter 2 don't
make it so I could just jump throw many
many know that well that was a
commercial
yeah they actually want to really put me
off to the idea I became sort of very
sort of puritanical about it I'm like no
this is like not the intended thing and
this is just like yeah you know turns
out if you could have a version of
Street Fighter 2 where you could have
like 90 fireballs on the screen it
doesn't actually make the game better it
doesn't what was so interesting is these
machines these hacks Street Fighter
machines became so popular that Capcom
had to respond to this and immediately
after Capcom had released Street Fighter
champion edition they released street
fighter two turbo yeah yeah which
incorporated a lot of the changes right
none of the most people had made in the
hacked version so like doing you can do
fire balls in the air but you could do
the hurricane kick you right and
suddenly had a fireball and all that
kind of stuff how come took the hacked
version and made a real game out of it
miss pac-man was a hack miss Pam it's
true yeah they were building that
company around the idea of we're gonna
make a board that if you're an arcade
game operator you can take your game pop
the board on and it's gonna use what's
already in there make a totally new game
out of it which at the time they didn't
really know if that was illegal or not I
know to even do that but yeah it was a
hack but what is your choice cream yeah
I always felt that the the the biggest
weakness of Super Mario Brothers 3
besides the fact that it was regressive
in the sense that they went from super
mario brothers to with four characters
into mario 3 with with one in Mario to
that introduced the Mario Luigi were
separate uh dudes with different powers
and then Mario 3 he went back to being a
palette swap of Mario but I felt its
biggest weakness was that it did not
have a save battery if I could go back
in time and change history like the epic
hack I would be like spend the money and
put a save battery in every copy of
Super Mario Bros 3 because then what
that would do was it transforms it from
this really quick you know kind of level
based experience into an almost mario
world style like open world kind of
thing because that game was huge the
game was eight worlds full o levels but
if you wanted to beat it you had to do
it in one sitting which meant you had to
work through every day unless you were
super good and we're gonna play through
everything then leave your nes on and of
course you know if the cat came by and
not be any
silver you'd lose all your stuff oh and
you'd be able to travel back and forth
between worlds instead of being locked
on what Matt yeah so that's my idea
Miyamoto all right wrong with it so
those are our ideal hacks what we would
do in a perfect world but we want to
know yours so what would you do to
change a class a game that you love let
us know in the comments don't say Mario
3 that was my idea say Mario 3